but here's what's happening in beijing
it's been happening all day 3.5 million
people got a message last night telling
them they had to get a test today they
have to get one on wednesday they'll
have to get one on friday so this is
coming to an end they have been getting
through it but this has been all day
long these huge huge queues here in
beijing the reason for that is because
they detected just 19 cases the other
day 29 reported uh today and an update
to that these are very small numbers but
they don't want to take any chances
because of what's been happening in
shanghai this what happened in shanghai
is a very similar situation they said
everyone has to do this mass testing
mass pcr testing the city went into
lockdown to happen to enable that and it
never came out of it it's still in
lockdown a very strict lockdown coming
up into its fifth week now the problem
with shanghai is that of course there
are those deaths you mentioned 51 a new
record since the early days of the
pandemic in wuhan back in 2020 but the
case numbers are stubbornly high around
20 000. they're not going up they're not
coming down so it looks like that
lockdown is going to exist and that's
why there is a lot of anxiety here in
beijing are we going to see the same
thing
are we going to see a lockdown a lot of
people have been preparing for that
they've been going to supermarkets
emptying the shelves the government has
said there's enough food people don't
have to worry about having seen the
scenes in shanghai those food shortages
with rotten food being delivered by the
government people here don't want to
take the same chance and the question
now is a lot of people think a lockdown
is coming will it be a short sharp one
like we've seen in other cities in china
shenzhen guangzhou down in the south
they had mass testing and lockdowns or
will it be that more permanent lockdown
we're seeing in shanghai but this is a
big deal for china beijing is the
capital uh it's always been the most
protected place in china it's very hard
to travel here over the past few days
they're still dealing with this outbreak
and this is because of course china is
pursuing that dynamic zero covid policy
it hasn't got the vaccination rate of
other countries so what it's doing two
and a half years epidemic is mass
testing like this mass lockdowns
affecting hundreds of millions of people
and no end in sight to that really